Speaker 1: wing and Republicans are
pretending that the leak of the Supreme
Court decision on abortion, which we discussed
yesterday, is worse than the Trump riot coup
insurrection of January six, 2021.
We knew they were going to do this,
and they are Axios with a very interesting three
page document. They obtained a three page memo
about the messaging that Republicans
want on this issue. And their focus is
the leak is terrible. The leak is a crime,
although they can't tell us what law was broken.
And it's an absolute travesty, not that abortion
rights are now going to be able to be brutally
curtailed, but that we learned about this decision
a few weeks earlier. And you can check out
this document, Axios linking to it and they are
focusing in on this issue of the leak is really
the problem. And we have a bunch of examples
of this, which I'm going to play for you. Now,
again, the real issue here is activist judges. The
right loves to say, oh, Democrats put up activist
judges who will legislate from the bench. All
of Trump's picks paid lip service during their
confirmation hearings to the Supreme Court, too. I
respect precedent. Precedent is important. And Roe
v Wade is the is precedent right now. And then,
as far as we know from the draft document, they're
all voting to overturn precedent. That's activist
judicial. That is judicial activism, without
a doubt. But Republicans want to focus on, oh,
the leak, the leak, the leak. We'll look at some
clips. Ted Cruz never finds a cynical opportunity
to make news when he sees it. He sees those
opportunities. Here he is saying this was probably
some left wing law clerk. This is a travesty.
Speaker 2: Draft opinion
that was leaked last night.
I have to say, it is utterly stunning that anyone
at the court would leak a draft opinion. You know.
Speaker 1: This is Ted Cruz, by the
way. He has this whole sincere concern
sort of posture down pat, one hand in the
pocket, the other hand kind of signaling
and using this kind of fake, sincere voice.
Speaker 2: After years of our nation's history,
this has never happened.
Speaker 1: And now it's
not true. It's never happened. It
actually happened with the Roe v
Wade decision in the seventies. But
who's going to let the facts get in
the way of a good story? I am appalled, right?
Speaker 2: This is the most egregious breach of
trust at the Supreme Court that has ever happened,
ever. Presumably some left wing law clerk.
Angry at the direction the court is going, decided
to betray his or her obligation, the trust that
Clark owed to his or her justice and to the court.
Speaker 1: The word presumably doing some pretty
heavy lifting there. No information about who
leaked this so far. Then Ted Cruz continued the
rounds and went on Fox News where he said he wants
the person who leaked this serving real jail time.
Speaker 2: Reason it was leaked is some left
wing presumably law clerk presumably wanted
to put political pressure on the five justices
that presumably are in the majority right now.
They wanted to put heat and they wanted to invoke
politics to try to get them to change their vote.
And by the way, if that left wing law clerk
succeeds, it will be the most grotesque
politicization of the Supreme Court in the history
of our nation. You mentioned an FBI investigation.
I hope there is a serious one. And I hope
whoever is responsible for this not only is fired
instantly, but is prosecuted and serves real jail
time for violating the confidences of the Supreme.
Speaker 1: Court now still unable to articulate an
actual crime that was committed. Then we go to The
Daily Wire host, Michael Knowles, whose program
I've appeared on. He says this He just straight
up says, this is worse than the Trump riots.
Speaker 2: Absolutely. Earth shattering stuff
and I won't let the libs get me down there
trying to gum this up. They're trying to
pressure the Conservatives to switch. What
the Conservatives need to do right now,
just come out with the opinion. I don't know
if it's in its final draft. This goes all the
way back to February, so presumably it's in
much better shape. Come out with the opinion.
If the opinion is substantially different from
this draft, then we will know that the Libs
have succeeded. Who at pressuring and threatening
violence. That's really what this is about, right?
You whip up all of the riots. You're going to
have a whole lot of mostly peaceful demonstrations
coming out with Molotov cocktails and rocks and
all the rest of it. And it will make a mockery
of our system of government. I never want to
hear about the the norms or norms or sacred
cherished democratic norms. I don't want to hear
it from the left anymore. I never want to hear the
stupid for his January 6th. This is so much more
egregious an attack on our democracy than January
6th ever was. It's not even comparable. Yeah.
Speaker 1: A decision leaking a few weeks early is
worse than the Trump riots with 700 plus alleged
criminals. Then we go over to Judge Jeanine. She
also wants jail time, doesn't know what the
crime is, but jail time she wants strictly.
Speaker 2: They were on opposite sides. So whoever
leaked this, we have to find out who the person
is and and charge them with a crime. I don't know
what the crime would be, whether it's some kind of
fraud on government property. I've heard there's
a statute fraud on the government that's very
broad that could include this kind of money.
Speaker 1: That's not going to work. Jeanine.
Sorry, that leaking a decision a few weeks early,
you could get fired. You're definitely not doing
what you're supposed to be doing in your job at
the Supreme Court. I don't doubt that. But this is
an issue for the supreme court as an employer to
figure out fraud on government property. Give me
a break. Greg GUTFELD, who's I guess a comedian.
He took a different approach where he had what I
guess counts as comedy, as a response to this.
Speaker 2: Republican presidents and Republican
senators. And you nominate conservative
judges, then you will get to overturn
Roe v Wade. So now both sides are going
to have to deal with the fallout on it.
Yeah. You know, Joey, I think you know, what.
Speaker 1: Scares me about this decision,
it's obviously going to target the truly
marginalized. And I speak of pregnant men.
Speaker 2: What are your thoughts?
Speaker 1: See how funny that is,
guys? That's comedy. The right is getting better
at comedy and it's really scaring us on the left.
And then lastly, right wing, kind of
I don't even know if she's an actress.
Right wing person, Gillian Anderson
tweeting, leaking a Supreme Court opinion
is far worse than anything that happened
on January 6th. And of course, it's not.
This is one approach. And then after the break,
we're going to talk about they're not going to
stop with just abortion. That's coming
up later. Find me on Twitter at D Pacman.